[Music]
they were called
rosenwald schools built between 1912 and
1937.
they provided an opportunity for
hundreds of thousands of poor
african-americans to be educated
in the segregated south in fact their
construction has been called one of the
most effective
philanthropic endeavors of the 20th
century but the story of the schools and
their benefactor remain
largely unknown today we traveled to
georgia last week to learn about the
past
and the impact of these institutions and
what they're still having
on us today from above it seems ordinary
a simple
white house an hour northwest of atlanta
but when the noble hill school was
constructed nearly a hundred years ago
it was revolutionary this was my school
before i said well we weren't even
allowed to be taught
marion coleman and four generations of
her family were educated here
one of thousands of schoolhouses built
over three decades
that transformed african-american
education in the rural south
we weren't really free to do or to think
that we could
accomplish more but when we were able to
get the school
and this just made the foundation so
that we could
really believe in ourselves and the
teachers helped us to know that we were
able to
move forward now they became known as
rosenwald schools named after wealthy
industrialist julius rosenwald
the president of retail giant sears
this is an important southern story this
is an important american story this
story transforms
america photographer andrew filer is
telling that story in black and white
a story that grew out of a friendship
between rosenwald the son of jewish
immigrants
and noted educator booker t washington
founding president of the tuskegee
institute from tuskegee the institute
which he founded
together they sought to reverse years of
inequality in
education because of slavery and
segregation
this story are the pillars of my life
the relationship between julius
rosenwald
and booker t washington is the
foundation
of the black jewish alliance that
becomes a pillar of the civil rights
movement
in 1912 they launched a pilot program
building six schools in alabama
requiring local communities to donate
the land
and raise matching funds what were they
trying to defeat
schools started off as being segregated
they were trying to get through that
part what does that do to a child
well to me that would dishearten them
and give them
a make them feel like they didn't matter
within 25 years 4978 schools were built
across
15 states buildings of basic design
two rooms with a removable partition
large windows to let in light
and a plain exterior to avoid unwanted
attention
these little schools had such a profound
impact can you put it into words there
are economists at the federal reserve
bank that have done five
studies at rosenwald schools and what
their their analysis shows is that prior
to world war one there was a large and
persistent black white education gap in
the south
that gap closes precipitously between
world war one and world war ii
and the single greatest driver of that
achievement and it is an achievement
is rosenwald schools i think of our
educational system today
i wonder what could be learned from
a deeper dive into the rosenwald
history we often think that problems in
america public policy problems in
america are so intractable
particularly those related to race at
the center of this story
is julius rosenwald in booker t
washington reaching across divides of
race
religion and region partnering with
black communities and
white school boards to fundamentally
change america
only about 500 schools remain relics of
a time before
legal segregation ended in 1954
some have been repurposed or rebuilt but
many are in disrepair
forgotten by the communities they served
filers spent three and a half years
documenting them
his photographs are on display at the
national center for civil and human
rights in atlanta
an effort to help preserve their legacy
why don't we know this
julius rosenwald is a very modest man he
did not
want he did not name these schools
rosenwald schools they become
known as rosenwald schools one of the
reasons why
we don't know the rosenwald name as much
as we know the names of some of his
philanthropic contemporaries like
carnegie rockefeller ford
they were monument builders they were he
was a legacy builder yes
that legacy is still being felt many of
those educated at rosenwald schools went
on to higher education
and in turn educated future generations
[Music]
and prominent leaders of the civil
rights movement like medgar evers
maya angelou and congressman john lewis
came through these institutions today
noble hill is a museum run by marion's
niece
valerie generations removed from the
school
but steeped in its history it's not just
african-american history to us it's also
american history this is not just a job
for me
this is legacy it is such an amazing
place
to go and to see how a community has so
embraced or re-embraced this school i
knew nothing about these schools makes
me want to visit noble hills i know i
know but there is a book
that uh that filer put together a better
life for their children
the forward written by john lewis
and entity says their partnership
demonstrates that concerted action
can make america better and the world
better education is the
corner of the cornerstone of democracy
come across the aisle come across
colors come across religion come
together and educate
yes beautiful piece michelle thank you
thank you chris libel shout out to him
as well
great job chris and gloria that's it